[Music]
thank you
presidential candidate Fernando
villalicencio was gunned down in Quito
after a political rally just 10 days
before general elections
as soon as he got out it took him around
30 seconds to get to the door and
shooting started I think it was more
than 30 shots we tried to find where
Fernando was and at that point we
realized he had been taken to the
hospital he was shot several times and
in the head
was surrounded by his bodyguards and
political allies authorities say at
least nine people were injured the
president has announced three days of
national mourning and declared a state
of exception
From This Moment the armed forces have
been mobilized Countrywide to ensure the
safety of citizens peace and the free
and Democratic elections of August 20.
police
the Attorney General says another six
people have been arrested
[Music]
a drug trafficking gang known as Los
Lobos has claimed responsibility Mia
vicencio's party members say he had
received death threats
he received death threats many times not
just once he said I'm not afraid I'm not
afraid members of the movement told him
he needed to wear a flak jacket but he
said nothing will happen
59 year old led the build Ecuador
movement a former journalist he exposed
political corruption at the highest
level including former president Rafael
Correa who was convicted and is in
hiding opinion polls suggested
biaficencio would have made it to the
Run of election
everything seems to indicate it was a
plot it appears to have been planned and
today we are paying the consequences
where is the security in this country if
a man has fought for more than 20 years
who was the best candidate to win is
this the way Legends the one in Ecuador
Ecuador is experiencing some of its
worst violence in recent history caused
by organized crime and drug trafficking
it spilled over into the electoral
process three weeks ago a congressional
and a mayoral candidate were also killed
while campaigning despite the insecurity
the national electoral Council says the
vote will go ahead as planned on August
the 20th Mariana sanchezida